now to a killing that stunned the
journalism community and wider public in
Pakistan arshad Sharif was a top TV news
anchor and critic of the powerful
military establishment he fled to Kenya
earlier this year after threats to his
life Sharif was shot dead by police on
Sunday when a car that he was traveling
in drove through a checkpoint outside
Nairobi police there say it was a case
of mistaken identity but that
explanation is being met with skepticism
calls are growing around the world for a
thorough transparent investigation into
sharif's death my condolences to you I
express my condolences to uh arshad's
colleagues to his loved ones to family
members uh to all those who knew him who
knew his work were deeply saddened by
the death of arshad Sharif we encourage
a full investigation by the government
of Kenya into his death
it's not entirely clear that we know all
the circumstances at this point
regarding what led to his death but we
do urge a full investigation
DW correspondent Felix Moringa is
following this story in Nairobi and he
has more on the circumstances
surrounding sharif's death fear
Asad Sharif met his death on Sunday
evening just outside Nairobi the police
in Kenya have since owned up to the
shooting incident which they say was a
case of mistaken identity they were
looking for a carjacked vehicle but the
license plate numbers did not nearly
match with the one they shot at the
Pakistan High Commissioner to Kenya on
Monday was that the MOG weather autopsy
was being conducted and she called for a
speed investigation into the incident
that led to Assad's death she also
promised that Usher's Sharif body would
be airlifted to Pakistan for a proper
burial an investigation has since
commenced on the shooting incident and
Assad sharif's vehicle towed to the
nearest police station
Felix Moringa there well earlier I spoke
with veteran journalist matyola John who
is a prominent critic of Pakistan's
Judiciary and Military who broadcasts on
his YouTube channel mjtv he knew arshad
Sharif will I asked him for his reaction
to sharif's killing
actually we had family terms my father
and his father or friends we used to
visit each other's families for a long
time and we worked together in one of
the Don News television channels in
Islamabad he was the bureau chief and I
was his Deputy better Chief so when I
heard about this tragic assassination of
Asha Sharif I immediately related it to
the circumstances in which Pakistani
journalists are living in Pakistan and
particularly the circumstances through
which Archer Sharif had to face and that
he had to leave the country it was very
unfortunate that arshad had to leave
Pakistan under difficult circumstances
there were many cases and registered by
the current government against him and
the powerful establishment military
establishment was also not happy and as
it was never happy with many of
journalists like us for the last six to
seven years
and we have been facing a lot of
pressure and persecution at the end of
the previous government as well and
journalists were really vulnerable to
many pressure and intimidation the
various threats the face torture the
first kidnapping and in some cases
murder in Islamabad and these incidents
were increasing during the previous
government of prime minister Imran Khan
and
one of the journalists was shot and he
was injured absar Alam another
journalist was tortured inside his house
and another of the journalists Hammond
Meer he was six seven years ago I mean
in 2014 there was an assassination
attempt on him in Karachi and there is
no clue about who did it in spite of the
fact that the top judges of the country
tried to probe the assassination attempt
on him until today the people have no
clue they are a judicial commission
report was prepared but it was never
made public so thank you thank you very
much for for outlining uh the repression
and the intimidation that journalists
including yourself uh have been facing
over over many many years now if I could
ask you about Assad Sharif
um what does his death represent to
society in Pakistan
all right
[Applause]
well the depth of access Sharif is a
very
strong message I think
to the people at large and the
journalists Committee in particular
and
never to speak against the powerful
government and the establishment it is
unfortunate
that we see a shot today not among us
and his family has been waiting for him
it was in very difficult circumstances
that he had to leave the country
but the message is very loud and clear
which is the same message that never
speak out to the powerful
establishment and the government
because the establishment is more
powerful than even the government so
this is the message unfortunately
so if I can ask you uh Kenyan
authorities are saying that this was a
case of mistaken identity
from where you are in Pakistan not in
Kenya do you you don't believe this I
take it
while being in Pakistan nobody will buy
this
theory of mistaken identity
I think this incident needs to be probed
and investigated thoroughly and the
Kenyan authorities whatever they say
there has to be a proper investigation
no police Authority across the world
will ever accept
its mistake or it's a criminal intention
uh even in Pakistan there are incidents
of extrajudicial killing by the police
and so therefore it is difficult to
believe that the some police officials
in Kenya just did it by mistake
that was Pakistani journalist Matthew
lejan